we've now described what we call the
instantaneous velocity at some time T
and we talked about it as a limit as
delta T goes to zero of the displacement
over the time which we wrote as the
derivative of the position function in
terms of I hat now this derivative we're
going to use a notation we'll just write
that as V of T I had where V of T is the
component of the instantaneous velocity
at time T now remember this is just a
symbol but we describe this as the
derivative of the position function
which I'll indicate as a function of
time and that's what we mean by the
component of the instantaneous velocity
now what we would like to do is ask
ourselves how does the velocity change
in time if the runner is increasing
their velocity well in general we'll do
exactly what we did before what we'd
like to introduce first is the concept
of the change in the velocity Delta D
which will describe as the velocity at
time T plus delta T minus the velocity
at time T so what we have in here is the
change the component of the change of
that velocity and this quantity is how
the velocity changed at a time interval
between T and T plus delta T remember
this is very specifically for this time
interval now we would like to do is take
the same limiting process let's take the
limit as delta T goes to 0 of this
change in velocity over time so we have
the limit as delta T goes to 0 of Delta
V delta T I hat and this quantity is
what we call the instantaneous
acceleration now as before what we're
doing is we're plotting the component of
the velocity as a function of time let's
just say again that we have some unusual
function I'll just draw it like this and
here's the picture at time T here's the
picture at time T plus delta T this
change Delta V over delta T this is the
T up here this is what we mean by let's
just remember we're plotting the
velocity as a function of time V of T
plus delta T and this quantity here
which is Delta V over delta T again we
can even call as we said before we can
call this average acceleration but what
we're interested in is as we take the
limit as delta T goes to zero then the
out of the slope changes you can see and
we continue this limiting process until
we shrink delta T down to zero and that
what we have here is this is the slope
of the tangent line
and that's what we call the
instantaneous acceleration so if we want
to use a notation we don't want to keep
on writing limit delta T goes to zero so
what we can write is a of T it has a
component a of T I have and that
component a of T this is precisely the
derivative of the velocity function as a
function of time and so now we've
described the position vector the
velocity vector and the acceleration
vector associated with motion